yeah time for Africa recap yet no that's
a nice song I can't take it in this is
my gift to you come back thanks buddy
come back from Africa thank you dude I
feel like I'm riding a horse in slow
motion
ah through the African I picture you
like this in slow motion let's just use
slow motion running from Aborigines just
Aborigines and Spears are going okay we
have edit that out that's so racist oh
there are no and then a hippo goes
Aboriginal then Bab they're my people
they're taking your kids me like this
yeah but they don't nobody's throwing
spears and just elbow your wife in the
face like new no I want I prefer to do
this musical I ride I prefer yeah I
prefer riding a horse and going cheetahs
cheetahs in the lines everything's
running with me because I'm a unifier
I'm a great unifier I don't see that all
that all the races of South Africa come
together under me as I'm riding you see
see when I hear this I picture you kind
of beloved guy who came to Staten Island
no I'm the one love dating Island it's
like satan island and you and you tried
jenna island but satan islands like
caught we try to give them bibles and
you're just running slow motion through
Africa now I give them the BIOS you man
a new dodging hippos you can't dodge a
hippo no catch it you're too quick for a
hippo dude you ready for my Africa recap
yeah bro all right now now that Liz just
i want to start with this though yeah
and you know this dude yeah I've never
been to Africa so I'm listening your
stories yeah but if you ever go on
another trip right and then tell me
everything you did if it's not it's
Africa yeah I've never been there
something yeah I know you mean but if
you ever go on vacation T and map out
your vacation days nice I cannot
emphasize enough for everyone this room
I don't give a [ __ ] right what you did
on your days now it doesn't matter okay
but Africa's different nobody I mean
they want that because Africa is
different it is different as long as
something happens in Africa yeah you
just stayed at the time something almost
happens do you understand what happened
no
thank God I got of it and you didn't say
anything the hippo in its way right okay
so nothing happened exactly but it could
potentially of ran you over
yeah but I went there to do so now by
the way let me say this about Cape Town
I know I've been a lot of places in the
world and I grew up a lot of places now
easy because you're on hyper modes I'm
gonna say this just got bad I'm gonna
say this out loud
okay town in some ways maybe in all the
ways it might be the most beautiful city
yeah like in the most beautiful place
I've ever seen Holly that you're excited
yeah back from town no better Malibu
like our spa by the way it pisses on
Malibu no no no look I'm here really
good I know it laughs at now really
excited no no Cape Town pisses on Malibu
you can't compare it there you go
that's around you all the time tabletop
Mountain that's crazy man you're a
minute away
oh it pisses on Hawaii Yap in Hawaii
Hawaii is beautiful
but I'm telling you right now k-town I
can't go nice how long on the flight
it's just too long I'll just tell me how
long well do you want to know first we
got to fly from LAX to New York City
that's gonna take you six sit with
tailwind Wright's flat maybe five and a
half you're lucky if the pilots buzzing
let's call it six Brennan cuz now we got
to sit in the airport for a little while
cuz we're taking an international flight
now you're gonna sit in the airport
let's call it three hours cuz you got to
be safe give yourself a three-hour
four-hour window now you get on your
plane well well in New York to where
it's from there
now you go New York Johannesburg which
is how far that'll take you with
tailwind with the win in your favor
you're looking at 14 and a half hours no
clothes okay now when you come back the
other way it's 16 and a half now you're
gonna get to Joburg gym bring up a map
of Africa for me yeah you're gonna get
to Joburg Joburg the old I believe
Diamond City or gold City remember
everything changed in south a lifetime
when they found diamonds and when they
found gold accomplice when the British
and the Dutch the Boer had their Wars go
down to the bottom and North Africa's
too dangerous to even talk about now
now um yeah but the bottom the ocean of
the chin then you're gonna take 8 then
you're gonna go on safari near Tilburg
so you're gonna take a look you're gonna
take a three-hour drive but you're gonna
get caught in some road
roadblocks and it'll take you five hours
to get the high road block just [ __ ]
happens man you know drunk driving stuff
are very modern place by the way I'm all
right oh my god
so South Africa is beautiful incredible
Cape Town again one of the most
incredible cities I've ever been to
maybe the most beautiful dude I heard
Madagascar is - haven't been to die for
now a couple things you need to know so
you flew in - I'm just trying to picture
this you know what's the baddest animal
in Africa hippo yeah one knows that well
we got the big five right we got we got
hippos we got rhinos we got a doula so
you guys Crocs we got [ __ ] that we
got elephants we got all these lions
water buffalo laughter there's one
animal there's one animal that that in
many ways and this is to the people that
are from there the native native whether
they're they're closer or they're Zulu
or they're quite quite whoever they are
they will tell you that there is one the
people that lived with the land will
tell you there's one animal that is kind
of inspired give me an idea he's not big
he's small and he's aggressive and he's
act like he he gets after it no he gets
after it now he gets after it not a
Wolverine you're getting close close
close with the Wolverine gets after it
man and and and he likes it in that
you're getting double did I like where
you're going keep going
he likes he digs he makes he's thick
he's small but he's he's got he's got
he's a digger and he'll bite you
and he's it bite and he's thick and he's
good yeah Plus no no no no you're in the
same area you're the Wolverine he likes
honey honey badger you're right sir all
the honey badger let me a couple things
about the honey badger you need to I'm a
normal football player it's a great
football player they will there was one
honey badger they watch this honey
badger he held off a pride alliance for
30 minutes before they took him down
honey badgers are known to go after a
male lions genitalia they'll bite his
balls off and he'll bleed out before he
dies
damn okay so heat the lion are just a
dict he'll just eat the dick and then
get taken out now here's the snake
though here's the thing about a snake
now now you got let me go through the
snakes that you got down there you got
the the spitting cobra
you got the
you got the green mamba you got the [ __ ]
black mamba you got and I saw one you
got the Boomslang the African Boomslang
you've got all poisons [ __ ] you got that
you got the goddamn look at that little
porcupine you got the video chin hold on
what are you in the 60s video
you got the honey badger you got what
else do you got a Python you got the
puff adder we'll go we'll get into puff
adders in a little bit all different
kinds of poison now when a honey badger
gets bit by one of these snakes check
this out
they just pass out they'll just die
they'll pass out and then they wake up
in their fine back their kind of immune
to the to the poison on top of that when
they get into these they get in the bees
and bee sting the [ __ ] out of them
they're there they're just fine they're
bad mother they look like a skunk and
yeah it's a skunk with a crew cut yeah
that's what they look like
yeah they don't [ __ ] around so did you
see one my family did I didn't get there
I got there late remember cuz I was
shooting go see anything they saw honey
badger which is rare to see really no
one really sees them now there's a time
that thing's killing that they're
fighting right there they're tiny and
they're a low fear so don't they pewter
glass this [ __ ] they aren't hearing a
peep out of anybody not a [ __ ] peep
they should call those guys they should
call them I ain't hearing a peep not
here can I kick that thing twenty yards
probably well that's where they're gonna
fight you dude and if they're if they
come sorry if I just ran up on watch
your balls bro watch your balls cuz if
they can bite a male lions balls off
they'll bite your [ __ ] balls off I'll
show you the other video they can hang a
full-frontal face bite from a [ __ ]
puff adder and pass out and wake up fine
look at this look at the Lions trying to
kill it even lions are carefully scrape
I'm gonna ask again did did you see what
my [ __ ] look at this oh oh look at this
thing biting it still fighting it that's
crazy
did you see one yourself though my
sister and they saw no no that's crazy
let me go honey badgers takes on six
line take on eyes lines before look at
this yeah I know I'm gonna ask you again
did you see my family saw no no
your eyes they're legendary look what
it's doing dude now I know it's good
what it's doing watch that anytime on
YouTube I'm gonna ask you again did
Bryan Callen see you honey badger well
we're gonna get into but did you we're
gonna get into now you have so far I
know but yes or no I didn't see well K
what we're getting alright but you're
making a good time no no you're making
that good point because I want to get
into that oh my god Harry on so you go
on the Safari you're going from
Galesburg so so so I I meet them for the
Cape Town leg and then we go to Port
Elizabeth outside there see if you have
to drive five hours well in in Port
Elizabeth you know I have to drive 50
minutes to think now now let me just
it's wonderful to get in a truck and see
elephants they're fascinating animals
lions and everything else but let's
let's just be honest when you're looking
at these incredible wild animals giraffe
antelope all these things even cheetah
and lion when you come up on them you
know what they're doing sleeping
absolutely not chilling there the
captain there lying in the [ __ ] dirt
and you know what you know what
elephants and every other animal like
Buffalo all those animals are doing
they're eating leaves slowly they're
chilling okay you know what a hippos
doing hanging out in the water and you
just see the Bears go how long can you
watch that but and also the the the it
factor of that Weir's off after about
the first 10 minutes like damn this
guy's almost Safari 40 minutes ago so so
so my theory on that is expressing human
beings are fascinated with seeing things
that are independent of themselves that
they know that don't need them when you
see an animal living in the wild and and
and it's fascinating to us that an
animal can live in the wild without any
help and it's you you are seeing this
ecosystem so in that sense that
fascination is never you never you never
get over it when you see an elephant
it's so incredible but don't please
understand I'm gonna make this call
elephant giraffe give me anything else
elephant giraffe can't kill man hello
zebra you know what they are they do
exactly what essentially cows do the
chill they chill and they eat now now if
you [ __ ] with an elephant I got can we
have a little dicey situation as you
know but that's a male lion with a honey
badger who eight who's not really
backing off really
well yeah I mean running yeah but he's
kind of he keeps turning to bite yeah no
but he's done a lion is aware that he
might get his Nye here he's deadly
running away but that's it's a lion at
the same time you know it is a lion yeah
it's a Lyon a um so you haven't asked me
about the great white no you know why
why because on the video post went jump
in with the great whites and behind you
says Makos and blue shuffles well we
went to where all the great whites are
though yeah well you dive with them yeah
how is it well I think diving we have to
understand the diving is not true what
you do is they submerge the tank and
it's you summer thing and you get in the
water with with little snorkel and you
just go under and you watch them now
what they do is they bait these giant
sharks in and it's incredible and you
see them up close and personal okay you
salt some very white here's problem be
when we got there when we took her it
was a three-hour drive from Cape Town
and we were all excited but the problem
is that the oceanographer there said
great whites had been very very rare
lately why she's as well we get there
over here this and I could tell right
away which what she was doing this T was
like if we ain't seen any so playing
damage-control she goes
they spin very rare we saw one a month
ago I said why is that said well the
thing is that um and by the way you can
swim to the shore where you're seeing
these great whites the 20 minutes away
beautiful pristine ocean beautiful water
like you can see right through all the
way to the bottom a couple orcas two
brothers isn't killing it two brothers
came into the bay OSHA has never
happened before now when I say the bay I
mean ocean as far as you can see sir and
these two orcas were well they would
they took out for great whites 20
footers so 20 footers but please
understand this when the orca takes out
a gray what they know it's an orca why
he's explained right or they just
deliver leaves the rest
it looks like surgically removed and oh
by the way the liver it's a 25% of a
great whites body it's 25% of his body
just eat damage just deliver think
through the gift for those washed up on
shore and they haven't seen a [ __ ]
great white in about a year great white
like check please yeah we'll go over
here to work goes cleared out an entire
row that's like you know that's like
driving three hours and not seen a great
white and just nothing oh that's like
going to see Michael Jackson concert and
right before 8:00 stage like listen
Michael's not come here I mean have a
guy just as good not Michael but you're
still gonna have fun I'll do you one
better
so we get there and all and all of a
sudden I see sharks and I'm like what
the [ __ ] they're there and they're
pretty big they're like eight footers
now those are bronze Whalers they're
beautiful sharks but they don't bite
people are mice I don't give a f--- on
to fish so we're in wetsuits to get and
I go not getting the water cuz I don't
give a [ __ ] because I've swam with
sharks like that nine years those are
the [ __ ] sharks right that's what
you do we're so spoiled I go and if
there's a great white I'll get in the
water otherwise not getting in the water
also there Chum in the water and you get
fish juice all over you and there's no
shower
[ __ ] off people are people are throwing
up because they're seasick I was like
see ya
damn not so and we seeing a great white
icy situation you saw the video with
some elephants that mock charged us in
it in a truck that's six times he's a
little extreme what's that villains does
it happen anyway no keep watching it so
does it like yeah you know well I will
say we didn't get all of it because
people were too afraid to film it
because there was a point where the the
giant bull elephant came up and they
it's six tons and we're in a two-ton
truck and they will flip the drum charts
and hit the truck it didn't it stops
short of that charge it was a little
scary and then you ain't great white
sure yeah we went to great white I did
see that I don't see the hell Brown and
then also you got a dicey situation the
elevators what happened
that guy's just stand there that wasn't
me either
Oh either way you had fun though men
food was good yeah food was good this
guy's crazy what's this guy doing man
halt stop is the elephant whisperer is
he ever he's not my Alan mix Smith
Safari I didn't do that either so at the
end of the day I got to pet a cheetah
and anybody who said that she was
drugged they're so stupid he was
definitely tired though no that's what
that Cheetahs older and that she was
hand-reared but the cheetah lives in the
bush the cheetah takes down we saw
killed the cheetah it killed that
cheetah is as wild as it gets however it
was hand reared and it's a
one-in-a-million cheetah it enjoys being
pet by everybody so it's it so what love
you a wild cheetah it has a red-hot
Ronaldo and you go and find it it has a
rate of 10 you go find it and then you
can pet it it was far easy so but but
how did it know to sit there and take
pictures who told it what today it sits
there because it loves this one guy the
guide that's there that raised it from
it's been around it's in some kind of
its own its mother time I guess it might
have been printed on him long story
short it goes out it does its hunting
and everything else and you can always
find at certain places he's all holders
to sometimes they bring him a cow leg
he'll eat 20 25 pounds of meat in a
sitting
but that day they actually can be quite
affectionate too cool he just sat there
and I let me pet him like don't do that
[ __ ] was it he wasn't that big dog
80 pounds and long I was shooter and
I've been it's bigger than you think
why run off kids are around you you'd
never let the kids run around never
because they're their prey drive yeah I
wouldn't let my kid around that [ __ ]
well that that I was a little bit you
know concerned about that yeah I'm not
gonna let my kids know it I just don't
trust an animal look at that [ __ ]
thing you know every time when I was
next way you could hear crying it purrs
all you can do at any time like you know
what I'm annoyed
thank well when I watch it get up it got
up really quickly and then and it saw
something in a distance I was gonna hunt
and I was like this thing is a [ __ ]
machine and then it would just disappear
then we just run off from the bush and
then come back we saw two days in a row
and then it just disappeared we didn't
see it again but it's in that game
reserve football though yeah what do
think it's in I think I'm heat has hip
issues mmm it's bowlegged
but they do fight they do like certain
people like this guy it he would call it
and it would just show up out of the
bush did you hear about that uh that
lady who's the volunteer that's a lie
who that's a lion and they thought they
locked up all the lines and went I'm
gonna go double round here shake things
out if anybody says that this lion is
safe to pet
I will never pet a letter remembered any
lion will you just put you're just
[ __ ] cheese did you finish you just
don't attack people who says that I know
see no god the guy said the guy said
that she died I never attacked
balls-deep never cheetah lions different
story why does a [ __ ] personal they
they would if they could be I don't they
don't do that they're they're not and
they're not as big they're an 80-pound
animal that can still [ __ ] you up but
still I am though a 500-pound lion 400
pound 300 pound female lion dude I'm not
[ __ ] with any of them no leopards
lions they brought the baboon I was like
do you know that she saw wild baboons as
soon as the baboons decide now I don't
like you face gone correct sir
correct get a good time over although
you got a once beautiful I didn't know
when you're coming back
Africa is a powder kiss South Africa is
a bit of a powder keg I'm really proud
of definition well so it's it's you know
the history without going into it cuz I
don't want to bore anybody but you but
but it was diamonds and gold it was
contested by the British colonized by
invited by the Dutch the Dutch and
actually some French Huguenots but it
was mostly Dutch and British when the
British South Africa the Dutch created
out it was for the e-trade the East
India trade company when they when they
founded this sort of like place called
Cape Town it was basically they had a
vegetable garden it was kind of be it
gonna be a stopover for ships for it to
get fresh vegetables to deal with scurvy
and all kinds of stuff pretty soon they
get there in like this place is the most
beautiful place in the world let's plant
yet they were farmers it the Dutch moves
in they came into contact with the
Khoikhoi who were herders and the also I
think that's how you pronounce it osa
the awesome that's how you say it
and they end the Zulu and the Zulu
nation the Dutch fought many wars with
them
you know and then like with everything
they had they had more better technology
push them they found diamonds and [ __ ]
right the British said Oh diamonds and
gold everybody and the British said
we'll take this and then they had look
Oh what's called the Boer Wars where the
ducks and the British fought and we get
that it remembers wait there's a longer
story inside that it's a powder cap
because it's it's it's got so many
different racial groups and it's you see
shanty towns as far as the eye can see
you see tips out of your townships out
of your fancy hotel you could see like
all those dude it's there's so much
poverty there and you have so many
refugees coming from Zimbabwe from the
Congo and they're considered that
they're there so when the Africans that
are there so you have the black Africans
what they call coloured they call
themselves coloured who are the Indian
they're Malaysian they're Indonesian
they came over during that they were
indentured servants and slaves after
when the blacks have been there so they
kind of live in their own separate
townships so black you have colored they
tend to have conflict then you have
British and Boer have conflict and now
it's kind of white becomes black and
it's a weird that the government just
passed like go along the government pass
thing called land the appropriation
without compensation so there's there's
this path this measure was passed by the
ANC to take land from white farmers
without compensation you see that right
there see that yeah I can see that's how
a lot of the population lives and
they're in some places there's 50
percent unemployment no education and
and and and now add to that all that
poverty add to that all the refugees
from the Congo from Zimbabwe and all
this place is coming down to get jobs
they take the jobs they're the ubirr
drivers they're the Busboys just like
Mexicans in this country so they're
resented by the population the resident
population the black and the color bear
so they're like these these these
immigrants are coming in right it never
ends build a wall it never [ __ ] ends
man Jesus Christ never ends
did you did you feel in danger at all
out there I didn't they're beautiful
wonderful people I went to Soweto I
heard a chauffeur when I was there alone
and I said I I went to the hotel said I
want somebody from Soweto to bring me
show us where Nelson Mandela's house was
and I go I want to eat African food and
I want to go where where I want to go to
that Township and I went
that Township and it's very poor and
stuff but it's been there forever it's
worth Nelson Mandela goes from they were
[ __ ] awesome I eat amazing African
food and I love chef now even be honest
yeah you didn't see any real Cheetos you
didn't see any great whites you didn't
touch a honey badger yeah as far as
[ __ ] hey man hey bro I'm just going
over here the Rhian recapping great food
yeah and I heard that great wine sure
sure haven't yeah that's every way I
world though yeah
did you fancy yourself any ladies of
Africa no I didn't but I was there with
my extended family I did not do that
aids is also rather rampant there
it's rather rampant I don't know if
you've been following anything but it's
it's everywhere for a while ask you
again yeah so did you fan self any so
did I put a condom on and brave African
ladies there are some beautiful African
ladies they're gorgeous
yes and beautiful people in Genesis and
I I did not know I wasn't scared I just
didn't wasn't that I was on safari with
my kids so I didn't take a minute to go
I'm gonna go into the township and get
my dick no did work as you look at your
family Go Daddy thing you know hunting
daddy's going hunting and I don't mean
hunting for by the way a lot of hunting
South Africa daddy needs to get this
white spear trimmed up yeah well a lot
of hunting in Africa sir if you want to
go and hunt anything from even Rhino
it's gonna cost you 300 grand - older
Rhino that's about to die or I blink
even elephant lions I don't know why
you'd want to do that but there's a lot
of trophy hunting in Africa a lot of
mister steal yo man yeah there's some
pretty girls there
oh yeah there's already girls there now
you want to go into the townships and as
mr. white guy and go don't go those
women want your money
see what happens see what happens you
might get the wrong girl and somebody
might show up and go hey bro I'm from
here and you're with my girl so what's
going on and you're the white devil
correct you why you picking up on my
girl
or you do you're all dog it and then you
get the gift that keeps on giving into
your death bed talking about AIDS or you
roll the dice brother yeah now it was
it's a
i-i have many worries for south africa i
don't i don't get a good time though it
was a good time yeah go back go back
nature you'd love cape town i'd go back
i would i would brave that that flight
to go to Cape Town 15 hours it's a long
way but God man then you got to take it
up to two hours to Cape Town the only
way to if I had stand up out there's the
only if there was busy habit up there
they have a great climate of the seat
and I've been offered to go there let me
to see not enough Brendan know probably
enough but it'd be amazing I got
recognized they're fighting a kid fans
fantastic Roku yep ah Cape Town comedy
club there you go look it's the oldest
city in our South Africa no I bet it's
cool I just have a hard time growing all
that distance you know probably good for
me you should yeah look apartheid which
means separation I think in Dutch or its
or in Afrikaans apartheid was went out
of was illegal was made illegal I think
in 1991 right when did Nelson Mandela
when was he freed 91 90 Jen you trying
to come with me do comedy in South
Africa
yes 1990 there it is they did food
though out there huh yeah change like
dude is it Thursday yeah they're there
what is it nine ten hours ahead I was
off 2021 they're honest I was locked up
I'm back on La time I've never been off
yeah it's 10:51 p.m. right no yeah no I
was opposite actually but yeah yeah it's
you was you know this last day of the
year bro yeah in New Year's rockin the
Irvine improv and I have an I had up in
a while night tonight oh my gosh oh I
didn't know that I'm at The Comedy Store
are you are you you could have come down
you should have told me dude you could
have come down
can you come down anyway what time is it
up [ __ ] I got Leo flowers opening for me
if I know them you can come down and be
great seven and ten I bought my slice my
sets are ten come on guys
it's at 8:00 and 10:00 at the Comedy
Store though you got sets dammit I
forgot you're doing that I don't know
why I didn't you could have come down no
you can't sell and think it's um oh
that's so much fun
dude what do you do it's been a good
year though huh it's been a great year I
think we had a great year and I think
the podcasts been better than ever like
really dude Audrey and this is in this
yes it's an amazing year do you have any
new year's resolution not at all I don't
mean that I live my resolutions okay Kat
do you have any New Year's resolutions
you've set those no never just kind of
do what I want to do yeah me too I don't
we don't need to wait for them in a year
nothing anyone does really anymore some
people do yeah the last for like two
months tops you don't have any not
really I don't believe I'm I just try my
phone every day should be you should be
what do you want to do and what and and
then do it figure out what you want to
do just get good at a language man not
not a language isn't Spanish I mean see
Africa a [ __ ] language of anything
kind what do you want to be good at get
your black bone jujitsu do you want to
do something that's yours whatever
whatever it is you know even if it's ten
years at least you're working towards
Oakley a lot
top ten yet and the number ones lose
weight the McKinney's shop cheating it's
a quick read more smoke cigarettes
brought the smartphone read more that is
a this is good this out a right now I
need number one number three and number
four don't need to lose number five nah
number six go for a walk by stay [ __ ]
you seven be punctual I'm always on time
eight travel travel for my job nine eat
fruit love watermelon here ten work hard
play harder go my god is that not the
most lamest work hard play hard babe I
hate I hate me I'll rest when I'm dead
not [ __ ] I need my rest are all dumb I
need my rest
yeah I need my sleep do you ever meet a
guy are you do do well on the cold
yeah man we've been over this you know
because it sounds like I'm such a [ __ ]
when it comes to I guess you're not
you're you south everyone hottest [ __ ]
oh it's hot as [ __ ] except for the
morning mosquitos exercise my evening
when you're in a truck and it's 5:00
a.m. 5:30
cold cold it's in Kenya's the same way
like you will freeze your [ __ ] ass
off in the morning it'll be it'll be
like 50 degrees 49 sometimes and then it
gets to be a hundred and ten or some
[ __ ] but meanwhile you see the
mosquitoes
I'm gonna [ __ ] no mosquitoes not
where I am now where I was is too dry
yes but dude I'm [ __ ] I'm sitting
there and um I mean I'm in like three
layers everybody else is we got flying
Sun it's cold you're like what the [ __ ]
am i doing enough and the dude who is
driving us who's this giant bore this
giant Dutch guy about as tan as a white
guy gets a guy I mean sun-baked the real
big bro a huge guy they're all huge you
know the Dutch you know the Dutch are
Samoans of your other big yeah there's
smalls of Europe not-not-not a snot a
flat has to be found you want to talk
about a group of people with biggest
legs and asses I've ever seen they're
all [ __ ] giants meanwhile bring up
the duck bring up the average height of
a of a Dutchman and the dude this giant
dude just just in shorts and t-shirt not
Colorado how are you not cold you don't
have any fat on you though be you know I
also have a sunken chest and you just
let your like thin so it freezes you to
your cold it does do because your
skeleton it goes through me yeah you you
don't feel that I know you're like envy
your thickness thick like a walrus dude
I envy it
average height six-foot win six-foot one
ever toss people in the world average
female 5 7 that's a big girl oh wait my
momma fathers are the slavs Bubba those
are the slobs here we go
5 9 for Dutchman Wow no that's for a
woman you're talking with southern Slavs
oh they're being done records being toss
in the world wow that's interesting
ok mmm well maybe we have that guy
calling or something what I toss race
dear yeah it's world world is revealed
as world's tallest oh no yeah there and
they're all so thick as [ __ ] so 6 feet
tall is the average
that's [ __ ] tall man yeah because the
average tall the average height in 510
here
five nines if I've done yeah are you
doing fee on New Year's County work in
there I'm working tomorrow morning so
tonight
Cheney joining night friends I'll be
here here yeah
not till midnight no but pretty close go
see a doctor cuz his nose is always
running yeah oh really
I think it's only running here though I
really do mostly just here yeah it's I
mean of leaky sinuses I'm worried about
that stuff doctors just non-stop
really oh you notice that Brian I don't
mean if 'ln I have not seen that but
maybe you have you you may have a
blockage yeah cuz I have um like a
blockage because my septum was all
[ __ ] up cuz I got punched in the nose
so I have like an area in the behind
inside that Eric irrigated with
saltwater I do that too doesn't work
doctor said you have a pocket there yes
clean out I'm getting checked out chin
getting it checked out that's my only
new year's resolution and just less
alcohol this is so stupid
I asked him on below the bed I said he
goes I just wanna stop drinking I how
many drinks do you have a day it was one
yeah listen okay fine live Alan leave
your [ __ ] life I drink I'm 40 every
day I drink every [ __ ] a beer after work
right sure we reserved about some wine
it's called living broke not not doing
that cat is there anything you need to
cut out if you have any are you addicted
anything uh no when I'm sad I eat like a
fat [ __ ] but that's about it honey -
really yeah I'm emotional eater no you
are not me - [ __ ] no I'm a when I'm
stressed I eat a lot when I'm stressed I
know I'm my golf hobbies in some
[ __ ] nam is it that's so interesting
like I'm stressed or like if I'm really
tired I eat horrible hmm you just eat a
lot when it what's your fruit of choice
get mmm a lot of noodles a lot of pasta
noodles from Asian pasta Asian noodles
and then Italian basta
I like dry noodles a lot interests like
the spicy Korean ones there's the best
never had them they're so good
a lot of people like to do challenges to
see if they can eat a bowl without
drinking any water or milk and it's
tough to you yeah it's pretty tough it's
good though if you like spicy that I
could do that I can handle it
did you spend Christmas in Africa I sure
did you did yeah did you get any gifts
no we didn't do any of that you didn't
know gift-giving your kids got no gift
well they're gonna get it so for me it
is cuz the morning looks terrible
Wednesday after the podcast I'm going to
Utah where they're gonna be skiing until
the 5th and then I come back and then
we're gonna do new Christmas gifts like
John six-six got a shitty Jesus no it's
fine for American but you're in Africa
hey your gift is [ __ ] a safari in
Africa I'd be pissed that my dad paid
for by the way be pissed I didn't dip in
my pocket one time not a peep uh-uh
nothing no change enough daddy pay for
everything I got scammed did I tell you
got scammed no loved it what happened
there's a guy no oh you told me this
story did I tell you a third time I did
I'd say it on the podcast yeah you did
really my days in Africa no grand six
grand you haven't heard from since right
you don't know I can tear it from the
amazing scan part is that he's like yo
what's up buddy I got your money soon
I'm like no you don't you lied to me the
guy they called me crying on the phone
saying you needed he's a baller Mercedes
well you know women obviously live in
you know living large all the time
always eating out he's I know him for
years I like him oh I got a text I need
I need a cran brotherly love I'm [ __ ]
my my I'm dealing kratom what uh-huh my
venmo accounts been frozen I'm like what
I don't know what that means right here
I'll give you a grand bro I should've
asked you I need another 14 I'm like
what he be so crazy I don't know him I'm
like you're good for it you have money I
don't care I go if you need what do you
need I got what is this excuse you mean
I don't want to talk about if you need
it I'll give it to you I'm sure you'll
pay me back
of course you'll pay me back I see you
bro I gotta get another lost or should I
give him five grand
all together cuz he keeps asking but
it's like these he's coming back I'm
coming back I'll just give you cash plus
an extra GI don't give me extra jegos
I'll give you a cat can I give you cash
I'm sorry I have it in a safe deposit
box he's a gambler
professional gambler so I'm like I don't
know what's going on but if you really
need money
I don't know what this is so weird but
your anyway I realize he calls my crying
he needs even more money I go oh this is
oh I'm not gonna see my money no never
Oh cut to three weeks later still a man
I'm gonna get it back my kill good job
so say he's got a pose I'm gonna go
ghost man you hustle them for first time
I've been I've been hustling I was like
that's someone you know that's you know
you know it's not hustle because you
know it's a right it's like such a weird
I was like she can be friend it's an
awkward I go and I always said I wrote
back I go embarrassing dude has high so
I know it's chump change what do you run
home at like around like it like that
like family yeah well not a big deal
it's not I just write them off though
huh what's he doing and kratom but some
people can do that they'll rip you off
like it's no big deal like though like
it's nothing to them yeah and you're
less yo path yeah but there's a whole
thing around and they stay in touch with
you and they're like and you're like
what are you doing terrible yeah you
suck when you're in events J yeah let's
talk a little bit about the fights
because I did you know I watched them
I'll give you my assessment and then you
tell me what you think assessment of
bonds drug use
now it's [ __ ] I listen to no
vegetate no Vince key explores the the
amount of so you listen Nowitzki so
you're good well I listen to not
Nowitzki Nowitzki was talking about what
the failure of findings were the
independent findings okay so so not from
not from you sada but from the
independent lab test that went out to
McLaren who is the most respected they
deal with it with the people did you
talk about the picograms were and and
and like what and how they had seen this
in other athletes so you can have a
reading which is a tiny tiny like it's a
whatever it is like like you know
because the smaller the problem is that
saw him yeah the problem is that these
tests are so specific now they're so
detailed that it you get you're picking
up on [ __ ] that could be the result of
losing a lot of weight and it's a
chlorine calm no that's not true
whatever it is that's not true
it could have been so whether he took
turn a ball you could
turn about two years ago okay after he
got cut but the bottom line is McLaren
said that whatever this is was not
performance enhancing it couldn't have
enhances performance and it had to have
been taken before he got caught
sanctioned the first time so here's the
problem with that yeah so so that's fine
for that in there right but if so for
that to be flagged means he took
something but took something if prior to
don't care don't you do you agreed he
took something I had to have taken some
right it had to be there some had to do
Yeah right
something have to do I would imagine
right yeah something like that
hold on so you take turnable but
although I had when I don't that's the
thing
so something popped up yeah so they're
saying yeah it's a very small amount
didn't help them but why is this getting
flattened yeah didn't happen to DC
doesn't happen to max Holloway yeah they
happen to Rhonda Rousey right there
happen to Holly Holm so why is it
happened now is it dick pills oh no that
doesn't make sense
yeah it's such a small trace amount if
it's in two years yeah what I think
Donna see happen is the reasons can flag
because either he has a high level
microdose program where these picograms
and these long-term metabolites or
something that's gonna get flagged well
he addressed micro dosing hold on key
yeah I know kind of it's such a small
trace amount that they know they can
work around it that's 1:30 or two years
ago before this I'm trust me it ain't
dick pills that's flagging their stuff
he took some real [ __ ] sure back in the
day sure and now cuz remember remember
we got big and started doing like the
deadlifting you ever seen the before and
after that and he was in a gym that's
known for that [ __ ] like he got [ __ ]
jacked
sure he might been on a cycle then maybe
and that's why that's right now that's
right either way here's the other here's
the other but and then to the picograms
thing yeah and me and Rogan had this
long discussion at the Comedy Store
about this here's the thing with the
Peter Graham thing so we're gonna say
Peter Graham this be around this period
they're not that big video hold on do
all his tests first to is like point to
- yeah next one point a point to pulsing
yeah they keep saying pulsing next six
tests clear yeah last test
giant number above those two other ones
that's just the pulsing yeah I don't
know we don't know though no one knows
right
I don't new one that says but I like I
like the McLaren what the reason he was
allowed to fight was the independent
McLaren report said that this was not
taken not allowed to fight Nevada them
you know why now because the Nevada
State Commission went hold on we get--we
time of picograms and stuff pops up why
is it so much higher than these other
tests though I don't know do you think
with that's why Nevada went right isn't
your conduct white Nevada went maybe
he's met maybe he's not saying stuff but
we can't say to him without looking more
into this so having said all that let me
make a lemon make a claim and you tell
me if you agree I believe John Jones is
the greatest fighter to ever step in the
Octagon I believe John Jones proved that
last night when he he's finished
everybody except for over on Sempra but
he was whatever but for the most part
John Jones
decidedly beat a great fighter like
Gustafson after that twice beautiful
incredible and in my opinion made no
doubt that took out dismantle DC mmm-hmm
dismantled Gustafson hmm everybody else
and I believe that it not only is he the
greatest fighter to ever step in the in
the Octagon I don't believe that he
needs the help and did it with the help
of well that that's the thing again I
think he took [ __ ] I do think he's
probably on [ __ ] now but none of that
matters right he's over the Raiders the
guys he fought were on [ __ ] too yes some
fighting now question you as districts
to the next to his name or not me i I
don't because I do because he's failed
so many tests
that's what's tough every other guys are
honest however I don't think he failed I
don't think he failed this test and
which is the reason he did though I'm
decided I'll be careful there because he
did
either way you paint this in the mail
that California so it depends on it
depends on what commission you're
talking they won't let him but fail and
test Finland test for you Sonic you
solid doesn't care about the Commission
but but but you saw he fell hold on bu
Sheldon you saw the test but you saw to
outsource because it was it was it was
an area where they had seen it before
but they didn't know how to another lead
yes so so so they didn't they they said
this is this is unchartered territory
we've seen it before but it's so small
we got an independent source and McLaren
our report came out and said this is not
a disqualifying number because of a B
and sure so I'm gonna go with them and
at the end of the day go with them cuz
he failed at SP well I can because when
the test was that's not the way history
works did he or did he not get flagged
for a positive test
he got floaters he got flagged for it he
got tests however how this he'd the book
you had on no no no you can't doesn't
work that black and white I said it's
black and white well no one Li test says
decease it's not black and white though
why because they allowed him to fight in
California so how for know we know that
it's not black Chael Sonnen was a lot of
fight in California true or false the
leading experts the leading outsource to
experts who were independent it wasn't
just McLaren it was another group - I
can't remember nobody talking about
these experts well they they had theirs
labs its labs that deal with everybody
essentially said it not only is he
cleared to go he didn't take anything in
at a time where it would make any
performance enhancing difference and so
all of those things were neutral so at
the end of the day they were they're
still not sure what to do with these
picogram results because they're so tiny
you have to take that into account so in
my opinion you can't just be black and
white about this
so why you have to keep okay B so what
about his last fight which is ruled in
no contest
so they all for the same peak for
beagles yeah so the last fight as well
from what I understand because the
reason he didn't get sanction as much as
he did well he it was it was not a huge
sanction was again because they came to
the conclusion wrong that it didn't it
was no performance in Lansing wrong the
reason why his suspension this time was
shorter is because he's an informant for
you sada and informant warm it for you
sada who so cooperation though yeah
that's not what Nowitzki said on the pot
exactly what he said but but he but
Rogan goes why didn't he get the same
suspensions Frank Maher right it's goes
that's because Jon Jones is an informant
he's helping with the investigation with
you sada and Bruno's hold on you're
telling me he's an informant for you
sided and he was that's exactly what I'm
say I mean that's why you're short
sentence okay because I let me ask you
something if your informant if you're in
for let's just say your informant for a
cocaine drug is that true I didn't hear
that on the substantial assistance to
sada
he provided substantial assistance to
asada what do we know what that means
that's that's where they're being kind
of like shady about it tough for him to
make friends in that gym if he's in for
MIT and nobody goes okay cuz so we don't
really I don't know exactly what it is
but I can't but the point is that the
second time being hold on don't skip
those with that don't see up over that
the reason why his sentence was less
this is from Nowitzki look this up
because John agreed to cooperate with
you sada on giving them information who
makes the choice is it the Commission or
is it you sada isn't it the Commission
who decides know what you're they go if
you're gonna help you sada catch other
people you get a short send is that what
the committee others together yes do we
know that we know that that's why
sentence is short okay that's from a
little so what know also hurt maybe I
miss her let me ask you some be yeah if
you're in a cocaine drug ring right and
your informant do you think you know
about cocaine sure yeah
otherwise what inform oh I'm not I'm not
it's not my contention that mr. Jones
has never done a performance enhancing
drug did I'm not saying that we're in
agreement here with that
yeah we're in ground I don't I don't
think he's juicy I don't think he was
juicing Saturday night right I think
it's from correct Wow so do i and so so
in my opinion but to me up to me a
failed test especially when hit with his
history it's it's very black-and-white
to me because other people aren't having
these problems say again second with him
failing that test with his history yeah
it should be taken more into
consideration if you're if you fail
three of them and the fourth floor like
dude it's just another picograms like
hold on so we're just gonna keep giving
past the problem is that the picogram we
there's a lot of evidence scientific
evidence that the picogram since this is
new stuff that the picogram may be a
result of stuff he did almost two years
that has to be taken into account
he's been sanctioned for that violation
sure twice right but here's another
thing be some people believe that that
picogram they know he's gonna flag for
is a masking agent for microdose things
okay but we can't go with some people we
have to only
with the people that actually make these
decisions and the independent labs like
McLaren that's all we can go on there's
not enough research done on it so
there's only one report that they're
talking about though it's very tough
they there's still new stuff and also
notes all know this game is dead this
[ __ ] is so detailed now cuz these labs
are trying out to each other that it's
could swung the other way a little bit
so much yeah I was impressed with no
Vince key by the way I like the one I
like the way he was talking you know he
on Rogen I think I think he has I think
he has everybody's best and I like the
way even John speaking about it even
afterwards and everything but I still
think you at the end of the day let's be
let's Inc I think peds is part of the
sport if you can judge John just based
on everybody else you met you're making
a huge mistake I do think he's dirty
I do think Nowitzki he's an employee of
the UFC is trying to his best to do
damage control I think he knows John you
stuff in the back of the day and now
they're trying to figure this out her
Nevada Athletic Commission just isn't
going to lose millions of dollars
because a picogram is in a big deal
that's it it there I caught this is
weird man for it to be larger from the
other two we all look more into this the
reason why it's so the reason why
there's an asterisk is because Jon Jones
did pop for a dick pill the head what
estrogen block or something else in turf
well and then it's running like a dick
pill - we don't we sadly so but forever
banned substances and then he popped for
Turner ball and there's no way they
found out in any of the supplements he
had no nothing at all to show that where
it came from
think about that but there are I've been
athletes that have been athletes
according to Nowitzki Olympic athletes
that have tested for picograms and if
that's what we feel literally be yep the
chlorinated something so that's all let
me ask you SB do we judge so again DC
max Holloway named the champs Woodley
[ __ ] Whittaker Rose Mighty Mouse no I
know picogram nothing ever no dick pills
other no dick pills no nothing no Pico
no plaque right there's no that right
right are we just gonna assume that Jon
Jones that's bad luck and he happens to
be the greatest fighter to ever fight
not yeah so I think that John yeah I
think that Jon Jones tomato coincidence
I do think you're right that you
have to go with the fact that at one
point this guy was doing something right
well you know why we're saying that
because it like you just said the exact
reason it there was that's what the
results say however is he the greatest
fighter to ever step in the Octagon 100%
one says any prove that without
unequivocally yesterday 100% did he
prove it without drugs yesterday in my
opinion 100% he's he is he is a
phenomenal well he was popped December
this month for the picograms whoo so how
do people grams get there probably
another subsidy I did wasn't performance
enhancing no but what has he's taking
them in the past I believe he probably
has but still it I just think he's
beyond a shadow of a doubt the greatest
fighter never step in the I'm sure yeah
but and he looks so impressive so let me
ask this let's say then his next fight
he fails again yeah what happens then
and it's picogram levels even higher
what do we do that I don't know does it
not count
I I do we just give them a flag I think
the science is going to tell us I think
we have to stick to the science and I
think we have to stick to independent
labs which is what's happening and well
let's let's see what this the experts
who really on the science to you though
remember these actions detailed stuff
that scientists are you know let's let's
go only with what the scientists say so
the sign says trickier study was like
only with clomiphene that's the closest
thing they can go with right and then
their study ended at like two 200
something days John Jones popped more
than 500 days afterwards with via they
did one study actually novitskiy said
that this is not unprecedented that
there has been long layoffs where you
were still seeing residual results for
200 days it's not death never after yeah
they stopped it up I don't know that
Mark III I don't know man I just don't
know none of us do but I we're just
going faced awful don't think I think I
think you're sitting Nowitzki has a hard
job yes and I think I get what you're
saying
however in my opinion John John fights
in my opinion no matter what like in
that situation I let him fight in that
situation I say you're glad he fought
I'm sure everyone's glad he fought if I
knew I watched it yeah but I like but at
what point do we just if you let's say
every this is every fight does he
just get a free pass to figure it out
they have to figure out within their
system because if you don't think they
feel ground keeps popping up P code but
no one else does yeah that knot is just
a free pass to do to pop all those
pilgrims well we know it's not we know
according to independent people like the
McLaren report because there's neither
stars enhancing there's none but we know
the dead that that according to the the
the science and experts out there that
these this is not and and this is why he
was exonerated it's not performance in
hands at the time of it yeah so you
heard the argument from Victor Conti
right so if there's different vats
because they're not cleaning these vats
with the acid all that stuff that you
need to do because they're they're going
through receptor cycling through stuff
right yeah so if there's Turner ball in
there but then there's a substance that
no one's able to detect it's like high
advanced substance and he's doing that
and the residue from the Torino ball is
what he's getting caught for sure I
won't even take [ __ ] aspirin without
asking the whiskey he called him and
goes can I take this nobody goes don't
take that take something else so so
they're love fighters like if you're
John Jones you better be [ __ ] I mean
they're I know fighters that are so
careful they're there because of this so
and they don't pop yeah exactly and John
Jones has a team that relies on them
that that's their guy and I and I think
Brendan is sufficiently I think Brendan
is is is cautiously skeptical because he
has a lot of experience in this world
let's just put it that way and I know
and I'm looking at this guy has detailed
first-hand experience with a lot of
people in the MMA world he lived this
whole world he's seen it and you know
when you talk to him he's gonna go he's
gonna go that's what you do you go like
this you go mmm
you have some doubts tricky and it's
very hard not to when you know as much
as you do about just it was just too
many too many boxes checked on John
Jones where he could have a high level
of designer drug which guys do sure hate
to tell you guys are taking stuff in
clearing you sided testing as we speak
in the NFL all over in the lead Baker
clarinet and when your two brothers are
in the NFL and you have the access to
that level any of the money trust me he
can get around one brother did pop four
older brothers
steroid test one help for something
synthetic marijuana yeah and the other
one fell for steroid PD yeah let's move
on to the great
Amanda Nunez is there any is is I mean
that was shocking because I work didn't
get anything off she got caught early
would you like to see a rematch or was
that definitive enough for you I don't
know what to do with that so you know
cyborg shouldn't have a she has no
fights left on a contract she's free
agent Dana said no rematch just cuz it
was in a competitive fight which I can't
understand it was competitive at all
yeah because I don't know what you do
like there's no all right so the
featherweight if if cyborg leaves there
there's nothing there
should they create that division force
side boy think you then I build it you
got to give cyborg another shot at it I
think that's the only option what else
you gonna do that's it there's nothing
else to do I mean I'd load Caesar cyborg
three signs and you give her a rematch
or cyborg doesn't resign just fold the
division that's it right Meegan that's
the only other place Meegan and there's
cats there they could fight every other
weekend
there's not there's no one there well
that was a bummer for cat getting that I
terrible one yeah that was a bummer
great night of fights though oh great
now you're I a favor I mean you're right
Hall dry Hall with that [ __ ] knockout
that veteran move
he was feet jobs words to what's that
his speech afterwards his sister with a
depression disorder yeah he's fighting
for her um what about what are the
fights were there that you found
impressive yes I looked amazing I did
guys Ryan Hall with amazing BJ looked
rough Vulcan Oski yeah
destroying Mendez and Chad Mendes great
night of fights yeah and our boy Andrei
Arlovski
I'm still doing the damn thing yeah
alright let's go some critter vents
sounds good all right cat okay so did
you guys see this video it's of a
wrestler who had to get his dreads cut
off before a match because the referee
wouldn't allow him to wear a head cover
to wrestle he wrestled the day before
without a problem and this is the video
that went viral yeah
you were in Africa even seen a thought
zoom Katniss here she had to keep
cutting until the referee said that he
was satisfied with it let's [ __ ] that
kid end up winning yeah
[Music]
the kid habits look at his face to let
the kid have his [ __ ] I know and the ref
has been known for doing racial [ __ ] he
got in a fight with another referee at a
some sort of like meeting he kept on
being aggressive with a black referee
called him the N word they gone - [ __ ]
that true though yeah yeah it's been
recorded and the referee the other
referee pushed him against a wall and
that's what was it was it a racist thing
that he had him cut his dreads there
what was the blow I don't understand why
he had him kind of Strads was it nobody
understands I understand cuz he's
wrestled before is when I was in high
school you couldn't have scruff you
weren't allowed to have scruff cuz they
you know it would
I don't do yeah you didn't wrestle in
high school but they remember that that
you had to have we had to have certain
things in fact the thing we had to have
our hair short - mm-hmm in high school
that was a weird rule so check to this
from Georgia this from Jordan burrows
the greatest wrestler on the plane right
now gold medalist Vic MELAS he said let
me tell y'all sickening this is I've
been wrestling for 25 years at every
level I have never once seen a person
required to cut their hair during a
match this is nonsense as a referee
you're a credit to check the hair the
nails of the of all wrestlers before a
match right my opinion is that this was
a combination of abuse of power racism
and just plain that's fair yeah yeah a
lot of people came up that guy sucks for
making them cut his hair you suck it was
also noted that the referee was actually
late to weigh in Jews and so he wasn't
able to give him the decision of getting
rid of his hair or not dude that takes a
long time to grow those treads that's a
bummer
I like those dreads yeah still one yeah
the Butler referee has been banned from
officiating anything within that school
district makes sense yeah we could camp
races referees you just can't well you
know he allegedly called the black
referee the n-word who knows I'd have to
see it I mean either way he's a shitty
guy
all right what else you guys get I said
a TKO this is her mom dad a ladder
though what is this buried in his
backyard yeah who she found the bodies
or what no she's doing an interview but
a Walmart santa was arrested recently
because he admitted to killing and
burying his two kids in his backyard
Jesus Christ one of their neighbors uh
went and reported his daughter missing
because the neighbor didn't see the
daughter for a while both of his kids
were homeschooled last year and she said
that she thought that the kids were dead
and so police came investigators
eventually got him to break down and he
pointed them to where he buried them
what a disgusting
whatever the stepmom the stepmoms mother
and the stepmothers boyfriend were all
arrested with in this case and right now
they're trying to find the biological
mother did they figure out how they
killed him it seemed like blunt-force
trauma
well they look at look at those guys
look at them they just look so bad they
look so evil this guy looks like that
right can you believe a [ __ ] mall
fanna who's that one piece of [ __ ] work
that's the stepmother
god I hope they burn in hell what else
yet so a clip resurfaced and whoever got
really mad about it again it's a clip of
Chris Rock saying that louis c.k is the
blackest white guy he knows and then
louis c.k proceeds to use the n-word and
they're all having a good time joking
around about it Ricky Gervais swooz
there he was also joking but Jerry
Seinfeld was very uncomfortable somebody
found this clip posted it on Twitter and
went viral and people are angry about it
let's see the clip is it on here mmm
using blackest white guy all the
negative things we think about black
people this [ __ ]
you're saying
maneger yes you are [ __ ] ever I don't
think he could do that oh I don't think
he has I mean you don't even understand
really you don't you don't really know
they're like I'm worthless
no like you know I wouldn't use it
anywhere no exactly these two these two
we sound ignorant sometimes you guys
don't that's it yes that's right losing
its play I don't believe it I don't
think you've ever said it probably in
your life no no no yeah that's it that's
the big huge difference between you and
me I think well you have so you found
the humor of it yeah I haven't found it
right nor do I seek it I mean you know
what's Jamel he'll say I know black
folks who are completely comfortable
with white people saying the n-word to
really have had to tell a few white
folks that I'm not that black person
still it systems the only person who was
uncomfortable here was Jerry Seinfeld me
and you know that it's yeah I get the
context and I don't like I don't know I
wouldn't be uncomfortable if the cameras
weren't on me and we were talking that
way cuz you know I don't think it makes
anybody in that room racist I'd be
uncomfortable do you guys have um
personal question do you guys have black
friends and then your other friends are
not black and then they say that word
now never in my life I grew up around
black kids I've never seen it either we
have has never been around no so a white
person will say the n-word like around
other bike no I have Asian friends
mostly right but I also have a black
friend and then some of them are so
close to him well they'll say you're my
this and I feel uncomfortable I said
don't say that around me might be
different if you're Asian might not but
still oh okay case by case basis I think
if you're around a bunch of black guys
that know where it's coming from then
you know
maybe they mean it from a good place but
for whatever reason it just makes me
feel super well we're all look I mean at
the end of the day it's the meaning
behind the word and and stuff like sure
yeah and you know I don't think that
that's the enemy racism I think this is
a bunch of head-fake over on this
direction I think there's 11 they're
real issues to think about you know
they're real issues to think about
that's fine I want them you know I don't
think it adds to the issue I don't think
it adds to the problem of racism I don't
think that adds to anything though I
mean it's helping anything I think it's
like I think you said it it's it's just
in poor taste
yeah like I never thought that but I
never thought jokes like that were funny
I've never used the word [ __ ] for
example in my stand-up I'd never let you
back before it was allowed I'd never use
you know why I didn't want to make
anybody feel bad but I just don't want
to do that so with the n-words gonna die
I would never do that
I heard some comic the other night after
I went up I'd stayed around and watch
other people said you heard this female
comic she was using she got back from
Atlanta and she was using a black
person's voice and that the black waiter
was there she's like what the [ __ ] I was
like yeah I don't like any of that and
because mainly like I knew if I use the
f-word the n-word
like that stuff is there's somebody in
your audience or somebody who got called
that in high school or when they were
younger or whatever and it wasn't coming
from a good place so I'm not really
interested as a comic and you look like
how many people are comfortable with
that to laugh at it though you know I'm
saying embarrassed her you don't know
what to do so you laugh you know what
I'm saying in general you enjoy the
crowds not gonna laugh at the most like
you know I don't I think that also with
louis c.k like in his mind i'm i'm so
black with I'm so comfortable and so in
love with black people that I can use it
and everybody knows it's coming
I don't really give a sh I didn't know
he was that comfortable black people
well I don't I don't really like world
know either way either way like I
understand why it's uncomfortable for
everybody yes black and you're not
uncomfortable with it you're still
uncomfortable because you got to be like
yeah it's okay when it comes from him
it's always got to be contextualized so
he can say he can't he
I'd rather not it's like Artie Lange
does a funny joke about that where they
like he was playing basketball a bunch
of brothers and they kept long no bad
that yeah they were using the word and
finally goes pass it and he uses
everything stop in slow motion you know
yeah so you know yeah I've never in my
life been around and I was especially in
high school like with my black friends
never ever did I just knew I just knew
louis c.k has a new bit now he's
catching heat from it cuz time about the
school shootings just cuz you went to
the school where a mass shooting
happened does that make you a hero or
some [ __ ] unless you were the one shot I
said not that yeah he's always been
pretty risk
I don't mind his comedy has always been
that guy you know comics job is to say
[ __ ] that makes you uncomfortable
sometimes it's fine as long as it's
funny you know or not yeah I'm not gonna
know hmm
you got to take responsibility for
everything you say it's all good what
else do yet who's that guy this guy that
is Omarion that's that keep going so
Chris Brown is in some legal troubles
because he has a capuchin monkey oh [ __ ]
listen monkey that was in The Hangover
yeah he posted something up of his
daughter and the monkey back in January
of 2017 and people got so upset about
him owning privately owning a monkey
that they reported him to people
yeah they reported him it turns out he
doesn't have a permit for the monkey and
now he's facing some legal troubles and
if convicted he faces up to at least six
months yeah they won't do anything but
he's trying to argue that he doesn't
technically own the monkey even though
they were able to get it from his house
on a random day sure you can play with
it like its name is Fiji the monkey that
comes over to my house when my my wife
has a birthday party is the monkey from
the hangover
- and super friendly but we don't want a
monkey they have to wear dress up monkey
for a birthday promotes all the animals
they they have a sanctuary where they
have wolves and huge snakes and
tarantula they bring them over your
house baboons and they bring over the
house for your kid all the kids that
we've got all the kids that never get to
see all these awesome those monkeys
alone about them it's an educational
experience that's cool people get really
weird yeah I got that they were they
were there were some comments that I
never read comments but I rode and I was
on the plane board I was and people
great this comments about the cheetah
they're like it's been drugged and
they're it's dangerous and they all this
[ __ ] that was like shut the [ __ ] up
and I was on safari and I said that
cheetah is there and it goes and hunts
and comes back that's one in a million
it just likes being pet by butyl I don't
think it's I understand that you know
it's a wild animal
oh here's the other thing that's [ __ ]
amazing about like so so why were all
the animals killed in South Africa like
when why like what do you mean well so
so all in any any safari you go on in
South Africa is in a game reserve
meaning it's it's pending by electric
fencing and why we're all a hundred
years ago they're way more animals in
South Africa now them they were 100
years ago 200 years ago why well 100
years ago why because you can't plant
crops or raise animals you cannot be a
farmer and have elephants before
electric fences have elephants and any
kind of cat like a cheetah a leopard a
lion an African links or any of those
because what happens is that if you
plant any crop pick any crop orange
trees whatever you want elephants will
come in and eat all of it and you ain't
getting rid of them because when
seventeen or thirty elephants come in in
tough enjoy trying to get rid of those
elephants they will stop you to [ __ ]
death they need all your things and
they'll come in at night and everything
else as well a lot of other animals if
you try to raise chickens pigs goat just
livestock around lions you know
efficient they are they all dying it's
yeah so what happened was if you want to
eat you got to kill everything like that
so that's why when they talk about
cheetahs being a pest
to Kenyan farmers or whatever they are
it's [ __ ] up as it is we don't live in
a world anymore where you can have food
production and those animals you have to
have electric fencing and everything
else but before that when you were a
farmer you couldn't have wolves wolves
you know they talked about how all the
wolves were killed in the West it could
be a farmer right you could not raise
their two efficient yeah I was in Napa
rogue and I were hunting in Napa
these [ __ ] llamas there in a 12-foot
fence a [ __ ] mountain lion jumped
over grabbed a llama and jumped back
over a 12 foot nice to watch that can
you imagine that yeah I can yeah I'd
love to see that [ __ ] took his llama
for the feds save the drama for your
llama save the drama I saw a gay rhino
oh yeah
he's [ __ ] another male nope now you
got my attention saw a rhino first of
all the Rhinos I saw have real bumpy
horns and they're kind of blunt from
fighting and using I saw one Rhino with
the longest most beautiful shiny horn
I've ever seen in my life
yeah a fashion-forward gay Rhino yeah
clearly he does know he does his polish
isn't the Brendan Schaub rhinos he's not
trying to fight while he does this rhyme
all eyes horn and [ __ ] girl was so sharp
and pointy long I was like what's with
the boy I was like that's a gay right
now he was like whatever over it it's
the bee job of Ryan oh that's right had
a swagger to a Stephanie shop of Ryan
and some cheetah thought of use on if
you are I know your your horn would be
so [ __ ] shiny yeah
any other huge dick they do they have
some dicks and I saw such big dick I saw
an elephant with a dick oh the reason we
had a dice situation with elefantes was
there was a female that was coming into
heat or she was getting puberty and all
the young bulls were like they have they
you want you think our horse has a dick
huh well to have a huge a I have to mate
you got a theater jump up on the other
horses
we saw one elephant in the bush he was a
big you do you know that the the male's
kind of Jesus let's exhale bro unless
they're gonna [ __ ] male stay out of they
see the movie the tree if you guys can't
see her and if just listen you seen that
movie tremors look it's what the cake
looks like the thing that comes out of
the ground that's an elephant you know
the dead look gray that when you when
you
locate elephants you have to relocate
the whole herd because it's female
female the leader so they're they're all
females the male's come around when they
want to [ __ ] then you know the Bulls as
they get older when the Bulls get older
they just go off on their own then they
go back when they want to do the digs
oh that one's short fat take that same
bro that's an Asian elephant big babies
chained and short fat dick just like
human yeah everything in Africa is
impossible to tame you know the Cape but
water buffalo that they ride in this
Philippines that's it you can't do that
with an African hell alone cape buffalo
kill Julia there you're not you're not
taming them they're not doing anything
come by stuff your rice paddy they do
write me this dude all up on his dick
bro will you gotta wash every inch that
that's an Asian elephant way easier to
domesticate that is dicks the size of
the man Washington uh-huh what else we
got and they will kill you eventually
sometimes they just have a fit they just
decided to stop to shoot at me
game over do you guys watch the local
news here I sure do do you know Chris
Burroughs passed away how crazy you know
what it is from they said they believe
it's a drug overdose yeah we're kind of
drug opiates they haven't done the
finish or it could have been here to mix
like sleeping pills or cocaine and it
just stopped there is weird stuff about
this too though so you know if you watch
the local news program you see him with
his family he has like a asian wife a
little daughter all right young guy yeah
it's like he looks like that most
happy-go-lucky family guy so he was
found in a hotel and with the like a
friend a guy friend that's all we know
and the guy friend was pretty know was
on the phone with the paramedics trying
to revive him everything so who knows
what was going on but you I'm a on a
knife what's going on cuz I don't go to
a hotel with my friend Brennan job like
late at night he has a family too but it
might've been his boy maybe they're
never known searching for chicks
he's like do I get these drugs they did
drugs or or maybe isn't as may be [ __ ]
above it is boy on the side I mean you
never know but and did a good job he
stayed there tried to help him out yeah
a bummer dude it could just be a good
friend who knows that's such a bit
sounds like they were doing a lot of
cocaine or something or Special K not
kill I don't think cocaine dude
oh yeah I think they were doing some
dicey [ __ ] or you make something but
sometimes you make a house cocktails
your heart just goes I'm tired I had a
doctor tell me that I had a doctor say
to me she was from Poland she said she
was looking at my ears I had a [ __ ]
here and there she goes don't do I
didn't they did a don't do cocaine don't
do it's very bad alright you can you can
just die your heart can cuz you're older
yeah yeah [ __ ] around did you look at
anyone oh [ __ ] doc cuz they cut it was
shitty sometimes yeah it can't be doing
cocaine up but I do but your starts
trying to hang on dude you don't you
don't want to make sleeping pills with
anxiety pills and all that [ __ ] then you
get the [ __ ] dicey you know that's
how the Joker died yeah
now the Joker my acting teacher died
because he got alternative medicine he
had a prostate cancer like mild prostate
cancer and they told him to take
potassium none of his blood took a beat
he was an extremist so he's like take
this pill and he goes I'm gonna take all
of them took all came out of the
bathroom and that entire right there
because what potassium does it stops
your heart want to take a lot of it you
take a lot of potassium it'll stop your
heart because it throws off your
electrical balances Christ and he died
right this is a bummer though yeah I saw
him on TV all the time all the time
dude's crazy married burros bites here's
a little segment where you goes to
different local restaurants yeah that
sucks I don't I never I don't know what
else you got alright this is a good news
I believe California will be the first
state to require all their pet stores to
have only rescues you can't have like
new breeds or whatever so we have poor
dogs yeah I don't like any of those laws
I appreciate it but leave it up them you
know [ __ ] dog what if I won of what
so well I can't kind of cool last thing
went to a pet store where the [ __ ] is a
pet store I don't know but there I sort
them off the internet where you get dogs
you mean yeah we're muff the Internet
yes skanky it's good though when you go
to a pet store
Pet Smart can't buy dogs there but maybe
it is good like you go to a pet store
kids are gonna want just a cute dog and
if they don't have a choice between a
Pomeranian I think it's good yeah I know
I'm I'm totally joking I think it's good
yeah tons of stretch I definitely when I
want a dog I don't like laws
yeah then they shipped to me in a box
and what water add water yep no yeah man
I want to cheat it now you should get
one what else you got just like a cat
Kevin Hart he bought his whole crew his
whole squad classic cars that's awesome
he could celebrate Satori maze out 90
million on he's definitely super super
into a vault I'm most successful play it
here let me see this video I haven't
seen this yet that hoodies dope do some
special form they have no idea what it
was I just surprised my whole team we're
old school wow that's a dope ass vet
they go cool Mustang there go sweet ass
Camaro Harry but that's sick Nova that's
dope Camaro that's [ __ ] sick it's
great his whole team are great guys too
the Volkswagen bug at the Volkswagen bug
come out by dammit that's mine what the
[ __ ] bro you got the Corvette he got the
Nova you have to come here I get the bug
that might be what into if that's your
thing is hilarious redone people that
was funny though I didn't know that
that's pretty cool though that's cool me
so awesome that's really cool all right
another what they called the called the
paper cut boys yeah oh yeah passed
plastic cup boys yeah they're all do I
like them every one of those guys are
great
there are they all comedians still I
think that some of it was great some of
them are gone forever yeah what else yet
another rich guy he bought his mom a
house this is a the rock and his mom so
they called it a Willy Wonka ticket cuz
she can pick any home anywhere and then
that's the gift that's amazing yeah any
home anywhere do we know what she picked
no I mean she's all Bel Air 67 guys mom
that's mom
Samoan right Sloan yeah and his dad's
black right yeah bro okay yeah sure luck
look at her I don't know bro
yeah man wish I had some she's white I
would love to be Simone oh that's a
great I want to be Samoan and Dutch that
bi whatever [ __ ] I wonder where she's
gonna live done where she's gonna pick
that be [ __ ] I wish I'd punch you or I
just block zoom out I wish you Samoan
and Dutch [ __ ] I'd punch you around I'd
be great man
I really would I just get my black belt
in jujitsu and just [ __ ] show up late
doing and just go okay I wish you would
do I'd squeeze you up a little bit
I'd love to squeeze you up like a zit
time for a squeeze out be oh god be such
a bully I wouldn't be come up to make
you my pet cheetah you shut up I'm not
gonna be your pet cheetah I'm not gonna
purr that's pretty dope I'd like to I'd
like to follow up where she picked on
how much ya cuz your son's the rock you
can pay 40 million a [ __ ] movie we
gonna battle there baby hey moms don't
want to buy like a crazy house to make
it no mom nice yeah but does it come
with the help you know like these are
maids it's gonna be the landscaping I'm
saying what else you got just this one
so this article says Anthony Lanting
Andrew Zimmern was fired but I think
he's just in hot water right now cuz he
did an interview with Fast Company and
he's gonna open up his own Chinese
restaurant in the Midwest and he was
saying something like in the Midwest all
the ones that are masquerading as real
Chinese restaurants are horseshit and
because of that they want to fire him
what's wrong with that
Chinese restaurant horse [ __ ] I don't
know not to me it means nothing
that's of people such [ __ ] I know men
we're getting crazy yeah well there's
that filming stopped on both shows cuz
it's horseshit
it's so stupid holy [ __ ] man you gotta
be careful now there's hot somebody
decides here you know network to depends
like you know though this is this
happens on Facebook Twitter everything
what else yet you somebody's deciding
people are deciding the people who are
pulling the strings are so politically
correct that they're they're this
tyrannical you can't did you can't say
anything it's gonna stop they're
interpreting I don't know it's gonna hit
a ceiling them is it because they're
there they're those people who are in
power are have been indoctrinated in
this sort of weird far
physiology it seems I don't know what's
going on where you KITT you're not even
given the benefit of the doubt they just
assume the worst survive when you say
something and so you can't everything
you've said is ms it was misinterpreted
it's a meaning is attached the worst
possible me maybe you were just making a
comment yeah and this is what happens
when the wrong ideas start taking shape
in people's brains and they get a good
education that [ __ ] Harvard or brown
and take that and and get into positions
of power huh for real yeah I do feel
like more you get it now if you say
there's a biological difference between
men and women even though the
overwhelming science suggests that take
a look at the animal will get intro
depends on your job like you're not
getting you know take it you know but
you can be corporate and get in trouble
and get fired this is horosho you this
is far [ __ ]
it's so hard all right this one more
yeah
all right this Texas dude found out here
30 rail snakes in his shed under right
under a shed bro hmm this my shed so
it's in the back but I'll show you
there's a little video of it here we
need have seen us in Africa crappy video
but see what lifts it up snake ease holy
[ __ ] though in Texas
Jesus Christ damn that's a lot of fun we
got run out there and [ __ ] those are a
lot of vipers right there that's a
shitload of vipers and they'll kill you
rattlesnakes bro fibers and the viper
family home rattlesnakes a viper ralph
two Vicryl with a rattle that's why
they're called rattlesnakes it's a
vibrant ahh bring up puff adder I want
to say that don't worry about it I got a
pee I don't want to see your stupid
African out there all over or dude hey
Vic you mean I'm all African out you
gotta be countered when you're high
table mountain on folder the better if
they're made a fool to the brim on your
Africa time slow-moving they'll bite you
I'm here I'm here bro I don't care about
your Africa trip anymore
I'm coming hey I'm out speaking of
Africa I'm out dude I'm going to Austin
the end of the month
stand-up at cap cities nice Jan 30 K I'm
one and two all right dude and come see
me at cap cities you surprised you're
not going to Africa you want to shut the
[ __ ] up about it
I got San Diego - we'll go through it
yeah that fantastic information did ah
next show for me Edmonton January 10th
through the 12th Edmonton Canada that is
then San Diego we got 20 days San Diego
January 19th Showtime special Sandia
Spreckels take you that tip at Cape for
Brian and myself Deepak a calm happy new
year this is the last show of the year
from the fire and the kid we're out